[Musica]
rapina in banca ragazzi quello volete
fare lesbian fare allora funziona così
trovate delle ceste dove ti sei
mangiarvi da qui e correte tutti dritti
è arrivata la banca se il vostro
obiettivo è distruggere le celle che
proteggono dei server sono quattro gli
dovete rompere tutti e quattro entro 10
minuti e avete vinto a udine dobbiamo
dipendere quindi questi ladri di polizia
dove molto in line come concetto pensavo
peggio
dai via troppo allora bersani li vedete
che sono segnati con delle pressioni sia
decisivo periodo potete riprendere
quelli perfetto indietro fu la tv la tv
non mi fa curare ma l'effetto ragazzi
posso cambiare compagno per cortesia
c'è qualcuno dei vostri sono stati di
ansia per le porzioni levi a me la fa
tevere non è vero secondo da vedere
calmatevi abbiamo tra l'altro e infinite
avete nove minuti di limite di tempo
ok va bene ragazzi che cioè pietro corri
corri contro due video dinosauri che la
gloria è nato sta indietro sta indietro
sono anche sento troppo le abbiamo di
tutto possiamo difendere ovviamente
possiamo costruire per difenderci
possiamo che devo sparare a voi cosi di
per distruggerli e si è da dire di
andare sul filone no nel mio secondo
ragazzi c'è un problema di basi non
possono anche sparare sparare
ok e che risponda edizione spero quasi a
fare fuori il primo solo uno hanno
demolito un pochettino non sono riuscite
faremo quindi abbiamo tante vite cioè
quello che vogliono finite in fini e gli
anziani
pietro spara volta pare ne vado a casa
pietro che cosa che compagni inutile dio
mio che male che male c'è aiuto perché
prossimo che hai mollato cose quali
l'oro e non lo sono capitati anche male
ma cos'è miu miu a che parte è noto se
vai dietro agli attacchi serra maliziosa
chi sei ombra
per cosa se c'erano dietro rompi server
utile copie truffa qual cosa stai
facendo non ora
mio dio che distrugge non so se non solo
hanno fatto fuori dai guai a te male
perché mi sta sparando non lo vedo male
che niente ma sono riuscito a capire
dove eri ma non sollecitano presto
distrutto un servo e sì perché se almeno
28 allora fare un server a 150 di vita
gli altri due sono ancora totalmente
folle
abbiamo ancora due serve pietro io a
fare di prendere al volo ma vuoi vedere
che quel cecchino stanno rompendo se c'è
chi come te arrivi a vederlo per
cecchini e non lo so che non ha idea di
dove siano con chi si sta facendo più
sul giro non li vedo bene tu sei l'eroe
via tronco serve non li vedo stato messo
cazzotti annotato per no no no no stanno
rompendo sul giro da qui server che
distrutto sputaci a tre minuti per farlo
fuori disputare sul server non sputo
luci bravo a cielo aperto
mamma mia quanto ci avete ammazzati
ragazze romene focus solo sui server
praticamente ti sei messo veramente con
il cecchino a spararsi
va bene il senso sposato a sam spylo
sbucciato completamenti team dove si
trova il lecchino che voglia fare la
stessa cosa ma da non copiare le parti
che va bene così alle tattiche ragazzi
non funziona così allora aspetta che
devo prendere il premio aprile pietro io
vado veloce da tutto quanto arrivo
arrivo dell'ansia al perdono sopra sopra
sopra sopra sopra dove dove aiuto
no no no no no no è surriscaldata ayachi
male
ma il lavoro è andato a totti serve
risentite le pietre ci stai soddisfa
riserve ma lo stesso ho rotto confermato
serve ma elezioni serve secondi sta
facendo una tattica strana o che trova
sexton veicolo ma iniziano a sparagli
map in cave lo vedo solo presso perso
per sempre sopra sopra dove questo
bellissimo inizio né quanti siete
colpiscono anche noi
ok per andarlo e 100 e colpisce anche
male tra primi addio pietro addio
costruisco almeno ma qualcosa mio dio un
posso costruire fa niente distretto
server di pietro a sparagli addio mia ma
cosa fai così fermo così facendo ma cosa
stai giocando tua hello kitty sta che
abbiamo già casa ford knight stati
campionato server di un io ma dai non
solo io vi sto facendo
pietro bove cozza ma lei non compare
soltanto comandante non ha sparato sono
presentate sconfitte di nuovo no ok
hanno curato tutto mio murato tutto
perché l'altro non sa di paese non è un
murale un costruire a caso fu minacciato
per siete fare stata cattivissima
ragatzu
stavo costruendo intorno non sono
riuscito a difendere ma nessuno ma ho
capito che c'è l'altro non fa nulla io
corro da colpa mia
paolo 3 contro un po ma questo fatto
fuori ma l'hai vista classifica alla
fine ma te ne sia reso conto
ti prego swee chai team va bene dai
l'ultima ma in difesa è difficile
preferito mi piace molto fateci il via e
siamo dei gentlemen diritti grazie e vi
sono dietro ubriaco non ci credo non ci
credo non è quanta vita avevi 43 di loro
molto meno spara licei 6 mar quanta vita
sei andata bravura fai fai forino dalla
barbie oggi arrivo da qui a fare un pò
niente tenere testa che mi spara non ci
arrivo ci sono troppe sbarre troppa
gente che difende ed altre le sbarre del
primo mezzo ci terrebbe server8 stimolo
dato mandato ai quasi sempre così
presente ma che di fatto due ottimi fare
l'altro in mezzo ferrero un po distrutto
che ti vogliono bunker ati server è
stato quelli all'inizio della partita ma
chi è questo pazzo ora io chiamate la
polizia
sette minuti dal via vai vai vai non ha
di nuovo il massacratore la base ma se
riscaldata non ci credo no ha detto
pietro vara sam ammassi mamma mia vengo
lido
madonna ti ammazzo te lo giuro ringoli
due abiti ti stacco la linea non è
possibile impegni solo con gli altri
non ci sono regole nella lotta alle
narrazioni corrente
no non ha troppo ero concentrata sul set
dai ragazzi 26 minuti ce la facciamo
ferocia facciamocelo impegnare e torta
mammamia sull'ansia veramente essa
succede un casino dove spara di due è
diventato di già questo devi morire
il gruppo alvi potete fare anche male
vedi attraverso di darle è potevo di
arrivare in macchina sono viper è solo
quella che manca viper viper e spingi
spingi sono riuscito a conferire arrivo
senso storico al nostro rimando la
famiglia
muoviti arrivato dio mio le costruzioni
sono fregato 34 minuti lifer e l'ultimo
attacco di farlo bene che può dare tutto
quella corretta riesco a farti strada
avrà una gravissima aiuto ma di ozil da
quella non si crede no no la società che
deve ricaricare adesso dai perché dovevo
ricaricare adesso devo ricaricare c'era
piede nel 1050 è qui dove s'è fatta
secondi va bene sei solo tu che puoi
farcela pace la madonna ma poi come
facessero come fate essere ovunque 78
non siete b2 siete 8 bravissimi ragazzi
non so che via con 189 chiuse ei ragazzi
questa è la rapina alla banca con pietro
estate fair e purtroppo avere pietro di
feriti e allora muove lo scrivo il
discorso è che se uno si impegna
rapinare una banca stesse fere sono un
po come tom e jerry io e pietro siamo io
sono gatto silvestro qua lui e e tipo
acqua e lui equa e titti non funzionano
lega non funziona però va beh spero che
vi sia piaciuto
lasciate un bel mi piace iscrivetevi al
canale e noi come sempre ci vediamo in
un prossimo quindi speriamo di fare
meglio di questo della ragazza
[Musica]